dobri now put your hands go together for
the hardcore demands gentle comedy your
husband yeah it's okay I'm going to work
really hard by Danny here it's our job
our worker
I like how Joe safety gets 90% oversee
that female again I think you owe Brenda
positive direction
no I respect you but you do I'm tired of
all these people they hate to be
yourself be yourself children no don't
be yourself be an awesome person and
then there's only one evil knievel
please another I've wanted them so what
are the chances that you're going to be
an awesome perfect yourself 50 percent
whatever the percentage you're gonna be
awesome prove it if you try to be an
officer little bit higher understand all
these people rushing around in traffic
putting my life in danger
dude what are you doing pretty late to
your board meeting where you going to
pollute the earth for then I'm doing
anything so I'm trying to kill me
everything women
people like that yes they're destroying
the economy and they're pulling for
Trump but people drop it in doing like a
million Mexicans worth of economic
damage libertarian rid of people who
pick apples for a living all day for a
guy who weekend to a more confident that
he actually does so hard is an air
conditioned group he was thinking 5,000
times better than your the perfect
there's a reason why they don't make
these documentaries about the day for
life of the CEO they go to [ __ ] so easy
hunted people i funny enough some people
like go down cultural English like Oh
porky not so dumb they don't use any way
you can visit short time what do you
take every one of your thousands
original your superior person to going
full-on arbitrary entities whatever
[Music]
I am like people with patriotic that's
kinda weird like people who have such a
low-level love for their fellow man in
an institution to tell that food alone
I just wanna appreciate that one their
love brother people to be sure when
someone's sitting down like I don't care
if you sit down
oh my god
[Music]
governmental is a product
[Music]
and I want to limp it there Okada
Andales clock but we do there's always a
gymnastics is perfect topping Pacific in
case they fall which anyone who taught
me out the way hey the way you know what
[ __ ] up want to be here and see support
we enjoy yourself this is head Lac
they're going to lunch
[Applause]
[Music]
yes we're together on the first we have
to get a connect on the young gunner on
the P British